Hey
how's it gone hey what's up
I've had the worst day I'm just so sick
of everything going wrong all the time
and now it looks like I'm going to lose
my job
well just talk to Janet Cod - Janet see
if you can move into her department
just talk to Janet what Janet got to do
with it why would I want to work in our
department
I don't like Janet this is good this is
really good because we've been telling
about this for ages you don't you don't
want to be there and the only reason you
wouldn't leave is because of the guilt
and now they've taken the guilt away
you're free this is it if you think
about this is the best thing we could
have happened how on earth is staring
down the barrel of unemployment suddenly
the best thing that could have happened
it's not good it's not a good situation
but that's how life isn't it sucks
great just just accept this this is
what's happening but that is not what I
need you to say what we can do is make
you feel better
when you a nice bath or in some pizza
you sit watch your film or something
determine Oh tonight right is that
literally your solution to every single
problem in the world have a bath and a
pizza I don't want to have a bath and a
pizza
just shut the peaceful in your mouth and
stop speaking for a second
[Music]
I'm going to stop trying to solve
everything and just listen to you so I
got really ready for the meeting and
they can't put both trains Oh my train
was delayed as well it was a bit of a
yeah had to get my bath
it was raining I didn't have my umbrella
so I turned out 45 minutes late looking
like a drowned rat to find Malcolm
during my presentation to the entire
team didn't give me any credit for it
[Music]
[Music]
you